tonight stiff charges against the driver
who killed
five local cyclists in a crash that
happened last week
yeah brian test results show the arizona
man had
meth in his system and may have also
fallen asleep
the crash happened last thursday on u.s
95 near searchlight about
60 miles south of las vegas orco mana is
live outside of las vegas cyclery near
town center and twain with how friends
of those victims are reacting tonight
well denise and brian this is just
adding another layer of heartache for
those closest to those cyclists
friends continue to drop off flowers and
candles at this memorial
as they try to come to terms with this
terrible tragedy we miss
our friends every day five bright lights
put out
too soon loved ones continue to remember
these cyclists who were killed in a
devastating crash last thursday on u.s
95
prosecutors now saying the truck driver
involved had meth
in his system there's a lot of
frustration a lot of anger sean tyrone
who often rode with the victims is in
shock
and says what happened was completely
avoidable someone made a choice
and and that choice cost you know five
of my friends their lives nevada highway
patrol says 45-year-old jordan barson
was arrested wednesday morning in
arizona
parson is being charged with six counts
each of felony dui
and reckless driving clark county
district attorney steve wolfson
telling eight news now barson fell
asleep and had a significant amount of
methamphetamine in his system when he
veered into the cyclist
he devastated the cycling community
and all of las vegas i mean people are
affected by this that's evidenced by
this growing ghost bike memorial outside
las vegas cyclery ghost bikes founder
pat treichle tells me
they want to focus on improving safety
for cyclists through education
and legislation we will be setting more
ghost bikes
as a visual reminder billboards put up
around town
honor the lives lost and direct people
to a memorial fund
sean saying the main mission right now
is to help the victims families
it's you know showing up and making sure
that they are you know
they have what they need
if convicted barson could face a lengthy
prison sentence
right now he's still in arizona waiting
to be extradited back to nevada
by the way if you would like to help the
victims families we have more
information on how to do that on our
website eight newsnow dot com
reporting live in las vegas tonight orca
mana 8 news now